Our goal is to avoid the message guessing attack.
The key idea is just to add some random padding
to make the message large and unpredictable.
There are lots of different ways to do this.
One is the public key cryptography standard number 1,
which is to replace the original message with 0 padding followed by a 10,
followed by some random bits, followed by a bite of 0s, followed by the original message.
This uses at least 64 random bits.
Depending on the length of the message and the size of n, it may use more.
This prevents the small message-space attack,
since even if the set of possible messages is fairly small,
an attacker needs to try all possible choices for the random bits,
which is at last 2^64 of them in order to test those messages.
There's a better way to do this,
which is known as optimal asymmetric encryption padding--OAEP.
I won't go into the details of that, but the main idea is to XOR the message
with the output of a cryptographic hash function that takes in a random value.
But the recipient can still decrypt the message,
because they can obtain the random value and XOR out
the result of the cryptographic hash.